you've had mixed reactions from people
about Princeton right yes how was that
how do you know well you know we get a
lot of stares it's rare you know in
where we were wrong to see
african-american families with you know
Caucasian babies he's gone again and so
we get a lot of stares I've had you know
police called on me where I've had to
yes show documentation that he's my son
um mad at that I would get mad at you
know we try to just kind of push it to
the side and just choose the love it's
like you'd rather somebody just say
something like instead of like no Seraph
not give you weird but just say
something it's just y'all are gonna be
performers it's just change and and I'm
not the babysitter cuz I get that a lot
to people that's that's like coming up
to asking if someone's pregnant don't do
it don't do it so my wife is white and
so we're biracial kids and she gets the
same thing and it's it you have a white
wife and my kids you know they look they
black you know so sometimes it Airport
and they're like questioning the kid was
a couple years is going to kid she
couldn't talk at the time he assumed
that the babysitter or something it's
just it's awkward it's awkward and the
melting pot of everyone you're keeping
in contact with all the biological
parents right yes opened I think that
that's a really cool yes it has to be
you know I think that it's really
important to keep them connected you
know to their birth families you know I
call it bump my bonus families I don't
want to ever put my children in a
position to where you know they're
questioning like well why didn't you you
know I know yeah you know I would rather
them know and especially that with I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this